هنا في هونغ كونغ
، لا تأخذ السلطات الصحية أي فرص عندما يتعلق
الأمر بهاتين الحالتين المؤكدة لهذا النوع الجديد الذي
يحتمل أن يكون أكثر عدوى والذي
تم تحديده لأول مرة في جنوب إفريقيا ، فقد كان في
الواقع مسافرًا من جنوب إفريقيا
رجلًا في الثلاثينيات من عمره ثبتت إصابته
في  فندق Regal Airport هو أحد
فنادق الحجر الصحي العديدة المخصصة هنا في
هونغ كونغ وفي الواقع الفندق الذي
أقيم فيه الآن على بعد طابقين فقط
من الطابق السابع حيث تقع
غرفتي في الطابق الخامس ، كان لديك أولاً
اختبار رجل جنوب إفريقيا  إيجابية وبعد
ذلك في غضون أسبوع ، كانت نتيجة اختبار رجل في الغرفة المقابلة
في الستينيات من العمر إيجابية أيضًا
على الرغم من أن السلطات الصحية تقول إن هذين
الشخصين لم يكن لهما أي اتصال جسدي مباشر
وأن كليهما تم تطعيمهما بالكامل ،
لذلك نتلقى الآن إشعارات في
غرفنا نحتاجها  لاستئجار أجهزة تنقية الهواء
إذا أردنا ممارسة الرياضة في الغرفة
بالطبع يجب على الجميع ارتداء قناع
كلما فتحوا الباب
لإخراج طعامهم أو وضع القمامة في الخارج.
احصل على بعض اللقطات السريعة عن طريق
إخراج ذراعي من الباب ويمكنك أن ترى
مدى قرب هذه الغرف من بعضها
داخل هذا الفندق ، كل كرسي مغطى بالبلاستيك
هو غرفة وكل هؤلاء
الأشخاص على مقربة من هذا القبيل والآن
أسئلة حول ما إذا كان هذا جديدًا
قد يكون المتغير أكثر عدوى من الواضح أن
القلق يتزايد وتقوم
السلطات الصحية بتكثيف اختبارات فيروس كورونا
لقد أجريت بالفعل اختبارين للفيروس
وكنت هنا لمدة يومين من
أجل الحجر الصحي الخاص بي فيما يتعلق بما
يحدث في هونغ كونغ التالية التي
تحدثت عنها بالفعل  تشديد القيود على
أطقم رحلات الشحن التي
قد تعيق موسم الشحن في العطلات ،
هذا هو واحد من
أكثر مراكز شحن البضائع ازدحامًا في العالم ، وعلى
الرغم من انخفاض سفر الركاب
بشكل كبير ، يخطط المزيد من الناس
للسفر مع عيد الميلاد القادم
وعطلة العام الجديد ناهيك عن الصينيين
العام الجديد وكذلك ريبلي سي إن هونغ
كونغ